you know Floyd Mayweather's on cameo
guess who charges more than you so he's
like the second-highest charging for
cameo but there's one person that
charges more any guesses what no any
other Christmas piercing like Chris is
charging like ten yeah it's not no okay
Katelyn dinner 25 now
whoa how much 25 hundred bucks yeah dude
I charge a hundred bucks and always will
and you donate to charity yeah I do well
lately I've been spending it but yes no
I do I do I actually haven't spent it
but yes I've spent on charity a lot of
money hmm
I know you guys both that's very nice I
know but because I get criticized for it
because now over my various charities
yeah okay I'm gonna tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]